well rail union leaders have warned MPS
there's still a lot left to talk about
if further strike action is to be
avoided mcwheeler knows all about it is
the General Secretary of the aslef Union
hi it's good to see you thanks for
joining us I was listening to you with
interest yesterday when you were
speaking to a committee of MPS and you
told them we're further away than we
started from a deal how can that be
well we negotiate in good faith you
might not like our responses and none of
us want to be in the position that we're
in but I found myself last week where
um a deal was announced in the Press on
a Friday afternoon late on a Friday
afternoon that can take many things that
we were around Red Lines we'd already
said no to many things we hadn't
discussed and basically were destroyed
our ability to actually eradicate every
agreement we've made in the last 140
years locally and nationally with no
rights renegotiate no trade Union is
going to give up the ability to speak my
office members
other plans for new talks what's going
to happen next is and the industry know
this they've been dealing with this in
the prime side sector for two two and a
half decades that any deal has to go to
my board my exactly committee
um I naturally won't be recommending
they will make the decision
um and depending on what they decide
we'll dictate whether we go back into
that format of talks again or what we do
in future
train drivers earn a lot of money 60
Grand the offer we're told from the rail
delivery group
describe it as a landmark outline
proposal it would give you eight percent
over two years which would mean that pay
would go up to about 65 000 pounds is
that not enough it's not quite true a
trouble is average salaries of a train
drivers more than that some in the city
companies some earn more and in many
years they earn significantly less about
the reality of the deal was that it was
14 RPI last year we're currently running
something similar this year we haven't
had a pay rise for four years in effect
it was a 20 pay cut for giving up every
term and condition we've got which has
been incredibly unfair and the value of
the deal would have been hundreds and
hundreds of millions of uh pounds in
productivity that you know the deal
itself doesn't make any economic sense
in English I perform but you must
appreciate that when we're seeing that
three million people have run out on the
prepay meters and I don't have any heat
and then we're looking at train drivers
who earn some of them over 65 000 pounds
that's a lot of money it's a lot of
money and neither you're right because
I've watched quite often do the politics
of Wembley you know we've what we've got
we've paid for in flexibility and
productivity down the years
um people doing the 11 hour terms would
be a 20 minute breaks five and a half
hours six hours from the seat many
people still driving traction that is 29
40 years old with no toilet facilities
the modern Railway isn't quite as people
imagine it we see a nice shiny Intercity
train going for me to be how much
involvement do you think the government
has in the negotiations behind the
scenes well that's part of the problem
um we don't actually work for the
government we're done with the DFT or
the treasury I've got 15 strikes on and
15 talks so we're a prime employee
battery from mobilio to first group to
trentalia to Advantage to whoever else
um but the people that we work for have
done a contractual deal with the
government limiting their ability to
give us a pay rise now we have free
collective bargaining now the value of
whatever you want to sell or buy is
precluded by what you're allowed to talk
about so part of this dispute arose from
the fact that when we went to talk to
our employers they said we can't talk to
you then we went to the government they
said no you've got to talk to your
employers so we months have been messed
around pushed on pillars to post before
we validate for strike action do you
find that this transport secretary is um
more willing to discuss with you I've
met with him once I found him incredibly
personable although apparently in the
Daily Mail they found me unpleasant
I hope not I don't find you unpleasant
um and you know I wanted to talk to
anybody we don't want to be on strike we
don't want to be losing money we want a
resolution but let's be a fair
resolution so what is it that you want
what is what are the main sticking
points for you guys well having had no
pay offer for four years and all of a
sudden getting one that's so untenable
is frightening I want somebody to come
to the table and release the shackles
talk to us properly about the True Value
about what they want delivered how they
want delivered it and if everybody
thinks that we can just because of the
current crisis give up everything we've
ever had for nothing it doesn't work
that way how worried are you though that
your members train drivers will become
almost like dinosaurs it does look as
though trains are becoming more and more
into the future driverless trades
um well actually mostly Victorian
infrastructure can't
sustained driverless trains it's a
distraction before the pandemic we were
actually looking at
um who's looking for driverless
technology though isn't it sorry hs2
will be hs2 bets purpose Bill most
trains run on Victorian infrastructure
with wonderful stations with Palisades
and nice pylons in the way and more
furniture that we can't see anything
also DOA wasn't designed for 13 car
trains with 1300 people one person on
there about our biggest problem is
society we've got train drivers and rail
staff afraid to go around part of our
Network at certain times day of night
prior to the pandemic sexual assaults
now Railways have gone up 180 and we'd
county lines with drugs people with
knives and acid the reality is the
society we live in when you talk to
passengers what they want they want a
cheaper safer but they want a visible
presence on Platforms in Booking offices
on trains and you can't have the
situation where the only person on the
railway is a train driver
are we looking at more strikes I believe
so when I don't know as I said we meet
next week to discuss the I'll call it a
non-offer
um and determine there's a lot of anger
out there I'm being inundated
um both on social media and in my inbox
by train drivers how dare you talk about
these things things that we have
rejected so I my board is eight train
drivers I imagine there'll be an equal
amount of passion next week
and so you will continue to strike um as
far unless you get the deal and it
doesn't look as though you're going to
get what you're looking for at this
stage the government though um is
bringing in legislation which means um
that will that you'll be breaking the
law if you strike
interesting
um what price democracy we might have
another debate another day between the
lobby and transparency Bill the protest
Bill uh the trade Union bill 2016 which
mechanic change in the courts and the
latest trade Union bill and this latest
legislation
um any form of indenture where people
can't withdraw their labor and can't
have a voice and actually will a pose I
imagine the whole trading movement will
do it
um we are moving in a direction of
society that does frighten me do you
think a way through this would be to how
because there's more and more unions
striking now members are striking
um a day of national strike a general
strike
um we have to be very very careful we're
allowed to do coordinated action and the
real problem is so many people have
jumped through so many different Hoops
are in such different places how you
create the action when you have to give
different notice periods and what you
have to do to comply at the legislation
it could be very very careful not to
take secondary action when you can be
sued
um and also most trade unions are out
there looking to do the best for their
members the point of time I look at the
hail service and my wife works in Health
Service for 48 years and nobody wants to
be out on strike and those people
deserve a massive Paradise but there is
um
a day of action National Action planned
for the first of February by the TUC do
you think that that would be viewed as a
general strike I think it'd be termed as
a general strike but from what I know
from the discussion that took place
um an awful lot of trade unions are
still balloting won't be in a place to
give the appropriate notice they won't
be a general strike per se New York
members won't take part in that on the
first of all again I won't know until
Monday when I meet with my board it's
getting tight then is it two weeks
notice you have to give we'll get 14
days notes but we can do anything 14
days from Monday okay it's good to talk
to you thank you very much India for
joining I don't find you unpleasant at
all thank you very much thank you